- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is compromise.
Over to you Ryan Gosling.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I think compromise...
is integral
to the creative process, and
it's more about finding a way
to make those compromises
into opportunities
and not see them as obstacles.
Otherwise you can get really stuck.
I think that's the only
way to keep moving forward
and being creative.
- So this is an interesting
message for this channel
because so often people are
coming in, saying go for it,
never give up, go, push
harder and here's a message
saying compromise.
And I think it's actually when you look
at the most successful entrepreneurs
and the most successful
leaders, it's both.
It's the genius of the and.
You will see that the
most successful leaders
are insanely stubborn for the why
but insanely flexible about the how
and this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs will fall short
because you're so obsessed
about doing this thing
in a particular way
that it may not work out
and chances are it won't.
Chances are that product
that you want to put out,
people may not like the design,
they may not like the functionality,
it may not work exactly
as you thought it would
and you need to tweak it,
you need to change it,
you need to listen,
you need to compromise.
But what you won't
compromise is the big vision.
What you won't compromise
on, is your one word,
your value right, like
this is what you stand for
and that's the line in the sand
and you're not going to go over it.
Where I think most people are
stubborn about small things,
I think most people are
stubborn about the wrong things.
I think most people are so stubborn
that they hold themselves back
because they're not willing to compromise
to get to the big goal.
What you need to have, is the ego
to believe that you can do
the big thing, the confidence
and the boldness to go
and chase that big dream
and then at the same time,
the humbleness for the cause.
You can do this big
thing, you're confident
you have the ego to do
it but the humbleness
to do anything needed to go out and do it.
Maybe that means you
have to sweep the floors.
Anything!
The great leaders will do anything
to move their cause
forward, as long as it falls
within the lines of who they are
but nothing is beneath them.
They'll get on the assembly
line and start making products
if they need to, they'll
make the phone calls
if they need to, they'll sweep the floors
if they need to.
And so, if you're being stubborn
about something right now
I would really challenge you to think,
"Does this actually matter?"
Because the most important
thing is advancing the cause.
Stubbornness around the
why, the mission, the cause
and flexibility around the
execution and how to do it.
That's my thoughts.
What do you think?
I want to know, in your
life, in your business,
what is non-negotiable,
what are you not willing
to compromise on, I'm curious.
Leave in the comments below,
I want to see your answers.
I also want to give a
big shout out to Jeff.
Jeff, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really
really really means a lot
to me man, appreciate the support.
Thank you guys for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
What's up Believe Nation.
To add some more perspective on this idea
of compromising, I'm going to
put a couple more bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- I have no education, I
had no high school diploma,
I didn't even have a GED
because I quit high school
halfway through grade 10.
I didn't have a lot of
options, I would be dishwasher,
a waiter, a custodial worker of some sort.
So I decided I might as well
go and do something creative,
I decided to go to the
comedy store, Laugh Factory
and The Improv, all of
those clubs every night
and make my 25 bucks a pop, a set.
It was my version of being a
waiter, it was a compromise
I decided to make.
Out of that came "In Living Color"
and out of that came touring, auditoriums,
5,000 seaters.
It was a really creative time.
I was able to prove,
that I didn't have to be
an impressionist, that I
had a personality of my own
and however abrasive it
might be from time to time.
Long story short, all of it
came from that compromise,
from that deciding to do
what I didn't want to do.
The things you can't
do or the things you're
not allowed to do, like if
the executives come and say
you can't do that, whatever
it is, it's too expesnive,
you get angry, you get
out of your mind about it
because you've been
clinging to this concept
and this image that you have
of how it should be done,
and invariably, most times,
after that storm has passed
and you actually sit down and go okay,
we can't do it that way, how can we do it,
you end up with something even better
than what was there before and you go,
that's the universe and
that's how it works.
It's like relationships,
it's like everything.
The thing that is taken away,
that you're clinging to,
that you're trying to fix and
you're trying to secure it,
make sure it doesn't go away.
You think your life will be destroyed,
everything will be ruined and
it's just the universe going,
no, I have something better for you.
Just have faith, sometimes
compromise is actually the way
to get to what you want
- I have a certain gene
in my body that allows me
to understand what someone else is saying
when they say we want to
sell a lot of these things.
Like I don't see selling
a bunch of something,
as the opposite of it being
interesting, or important,
or meaningful.
I've always seen it from both sides
and it's a really interesting
place that I'm in right now.
You do have to balance.
If you saw my iTunes playlist,
I could have a conversation
with anybody at Stereogum or Pitchfork
but what I do with Columbia
Records as the artiste
that I am with the records that I make
under the contract that
I have, I'm taking all
of my influences and I'm
trying to convert them
into pop music, that's my job right now.
It's not the only thing I can do,
and it's not the only thing I will do,
but as long as I'm still
trying to make pop songs,
I want to play by pop rules.
I want to listen to top 20 and
figure out what's going on,
I don't want to fall behind.
I'm trying to take all the
elements of music that I love,
that I'm well versed in and convert them
into music that a lot
of people can get into.
I don't know why I do that.
A lot of people can't, a lot of people
find the compromise maddening.
I see it as another challenge
and I see it as another talent,
like the ultimate talent of restraint.
- All filmmaking is
intelligent compromise,
that's the whole process we go through.
I mean, Con will be
able to vouch for this,
no matter what your budget,
you never have enough time
you never have enough money.
It's weird when you're doing a huge film,
you're in the same position you were,
when you were doing a tiny film.
And there's a good reason for that,
you're always trying to
get as much on screen
as you possibly can.
And so whatever the box
that's built for you
by the economics of the
project you're always trying
to push up against those walls
and so you need help from your team
in terms of how arrange things
and how you make that work.
- Waking up every
morning and compromising.
You have this idea, this
ideal of what you want
to do that day and you then, you know,
it just gets stripped
away and stripped away
and stripped away and stripped away,
except for those magnificent moments
when they cast does something
that you couldn't imagine
and you go wow, that is really awesome.
And then you immediately get a feeling
of dread, because you're expecting then
as soon as you say cut,
that someone will say
yeah, we missed the focus,
there was a boom in the shot,
there was an extra in the
background, who tripped and fell,
whatever the thing is
that ruined the moment,
that you may not get back again.